gang let's talk about that middle class
famous tour baby coming to a town near
you the hottest thing on the road right
now we've been zipping all over the
country and we're coming to a town near
you kippy straighten them out first of
all we got a second show out in chicago
sold the first one out yes we did zany's
still some tickets left for the late
show then we're over there in rosemont
tickets are moving for that so get them
goddamn
then we're also going to be in
pittsburgh buffalo and detroit get them
now before they're gone stand-up show we
play ayg with the crowd you've seen the
clips what are we doing come see us
bring the homies bring the bozos bring
the squad do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
r.u garbage hey it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out if they grow to be
classy yeah or if they're just a big old
piece of trash
i'm your host holy coming at you on a
beautiful day down here in aunt today's
basement she's outside in the backyard
getting a little sun okay yeah
bottomless oh which is a strange choice
no and she could use a trim i could tell
you that much get that michael who's
coming at you from across the table
unamused this week i failed them yet
again
there's a family episode yeah just got
back from tejas yeah we're hanging out
uh-huh we're back here at tutti's sure
are you're looking good you got a new
jackie thanks down there in texas
feeling pretty good ladies and gentlemen
my best pal the guy that forehead
magazine called number one in their book
kevin james ryan did you just tell me
i'm feeling good hey
this is kj if he's feeling good what's
up everybody thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate if you
subscribe on itunes fall video available
youtube and as you know those numbers
are true
uh and then obviously www.patreon.com
come on i mean aside from the bonus
episodes you get every week aside from
the ayg bonus aside from the [ __ ]
hard feelings aside from the monthly
live streams i mean we just booked
disney taking a big man down to disney
for the first time that video is going
to be up there we got the ten thousand
dollar on black spin and ac
coming pretty [ __ ] soon by the way
scheduling that
uh we got just bonus videos from the
shore cribs car video everything check
it the [ __ ] out gang but that hard
feelings that's the money maker man
that's what people tune in for
up and down you're smoking cigarettes
you're watching it what's gonna happen
is he gonna get fatter is he gonna get
skinnier oh fat court by the way we're
in the middle of [ __ ] fat court
season two
this time i put the system on trial
how about a nice quick sizzler on trial
how about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
he's got the midas touch he's got long
flowing locks of hair and a beard
and a [ __ ] like a big old sausage
it's t-boned mcmuffin i saw that thing
poking out of the underwear down at the
airbnb god damn the rumors are true a
little anteater popping out my
reputation precedes me gentlemen t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen got damaged show
him some respect ebay what's up dudes my
mom listens to the show uh she knows
she's the one who gave it to you
dude speaking of that ten thousand
dollar bet yeah i've met aka one akash
singh's wife yeah and watching who's
doubling it by the way and watch his
matchup
what
his wife's not doubling he's doubled it
correct akash is doubling it and i
watched him tell her that for the first
time 20 seconds after meeting me
i am her least favorite person on earth
that is no bueno
it's 20k we're throwing down yikes
it's either gonna be a great night
or a really bad year sure
give me one or the other but we're doing
it
we're doing it we're new money we're
doing it we're either getting stakes or
no more health insurance one of the
others oh he's gonna walk out of the
bellagio straight into citizen one bank
looking for a loan now if we lose i'm
gonna go outside
shoot myself have somebody
have somebody hit me in the head with a
baseball bat and i'm gonna deny the
whole thing and actually i don't know
what you guys are talking about that's
another one
that's another guy's 410 pounds at the
blackjack table probably the same guy's
smoking over in l.a
anywho gang it's a family episode it's
just us we're back we want to have a
nice quiet evening just us and the bozos
and the homies sure hanging out um
i might have asked you this before i'm
listening but i've been dealing with it
a little bit more lately
um
[Music]
watch your belly button
routine
what do you have one
no
i treat my belly button like i treat my
feet grab it is safety cleaned itself
they're self-cleaning you don't scrub
your feet no you don't wash your feet
now
wow that's weird i can't even reach my
feet and i use my brush
same thing i do with my grundle
let's scrub it all out that poor brush
that's the dude the best the best part
of that that brush's day is your feet
that's bad news
i'll even hang it in the shower uh oh no
it's [ __ ] day
it's always that's all day um
do uh yeah clean it
it cleans itself
water gets in there i mean
i i think our belly buttons live very
differently we talked about this you
smelled my belly button on an episode
yeah it was horrific yeah thank you
don't don't get me wrong mine will get
ripe if i'm like if it's sweaty or
whatever it gets cheesy yeah well it's
the difference between a kiddie pool on
kippy and an olympic-sized swimming pool
there's not a whole bunch that can go
around a trench you've got a bunch of
kids hanging out there like they're at
the quarry yeah getting trench foot and
[ __ ] i got two subs down there
wrecked on the bottom on the floor
that's coral reef growing in that bad
boy
they go to your belly button to sink
ships to manufacture coral reefs a
couple of subway cars in there too tiger
shark breeding ground down there giant
squid megalodon fighting in there too
well the reason i ask is because i have
a nice little routine now when i get out
of the shower okay i take it you get out
you do it huh
that'd be a pre
that seems like shaving to me if you
have a routine no i just put i i get out
of the shower
i literally a chill just ran through my
spine dude i swear to god
i get out of the shower uh-huh okay
which i started doing your thing by the
way what's my thing by don't be stealing
my thing don't th the wiping yourself
off with your hand before you actually
get out yeah like a civilized human
never did it before a lot of water does
come off it all comes off listen this is
what you look like
wow
it's like a squeegee you got to take
care of the head first that's where most
of the moisture is held
your hair it's like cutting a sneaker
you gotta [ __ ]
if you dry your hair first and then work
your way down you do a
slurp a couple of these it's like it's
like you're telling them to steal home
you know what i mean
[Laughter]
uh you do a couple of them down to the
you know whatever yeah try to although
what you know i do a couple of cups of
water come off you then i get out and i
do my ears i do my ears every day q-tips
i use one q-tip one side one side throw
that out and then i get another q-tip
put it in alcohol and i just go in there
and
what do we do
what kind of alcohol are we talking
captain
jack what are we doing
you use rubbing alcohol in your belly
button every day yeah why is that bad
it seems like overkill no it does i want
to keep it clean i'm trying to take care
of myself i mean i was also not an open
wound is it
it bleeds sometimes
is that bad it ain't good police in
there with gunpowder cauterizing his
belly button he's got a belt in his
mouth
do it doc
do it yeah what's with this civil war
[ __ ] healthcare you got going on
everything clean out my belly button
like a gentleman so it doesn't smell
anymore i'm trying to improve myself
i also struck oil down there too
a couple of derrick scouts like the
clampetts um
that's i mean i know i'm just shocked
that you're cleaning your belly button
with alcohol i'm good for good on you if
it helps the body i clean my belly
button with alcohol and i floss those
are the two things i'm really good at
everything else i really gotta pick up
in life yeah the whole situation those
that seem like you know
very minor details when it comes to your
your health and happiness is flossing
and
alcohol in the belly button sure well
toby and i were talking in the in the
vehicle on our way on our way over i
just uh i just cut the lawn down there
your pubes did you cleaned it up did you
do it
she's a good woman
tell you that
couples do that kind of [ __ ] for each
other yeah weirdos
i'm not shaving me my wife don't shave
each other really what
that's crazy what are you guys barbers
it's like going to the vet or something
yeah trim me up
because here's my problem
can i get real for a second no no man
between the belly button
and your weird sexual proclivities i'm
not sexual proclivities though i do have
them ladies and gentlemen if you ever
get the opportunity to throw age foley
under the bus you gotta give it a whirl
it's a good time
told you that confidence you piece of
[ __ ]
you ride in the back from that one
at least tell me you use the lawnmower
4.0 of course i did i'm not a [ __ ] i
don't know if that's this week maybe we
bleep it
[Laughter]
just says naroco
um
well here's my sitch he's national
leading brand
here's my sick what
i i can pick up it's probably not easy
for you no though yeah of course i mean
that's a given it's not easy and my
brush won't do it um nothing on that all
right um
but the uh
things build up down there like what
it's a it's just it's among the cheese
it's an odd yet appealing aroma
i believe the cheese i believe it's a
little urine
probably some semen in the hair in the
hair
because when you put it back
what when you tinkle and then you put it
back there's still a dribble or two it
gets in the hair and wait where pubes
smell weird
they don't smell great
well not now now they do put it back
yeah it sounds like it's detachable like
it's a cat stick
what do you don't they got corkscrews or
something i'm out that's why yeah that's
why i don't do cats
yeah i'd never give me a red rocket
something i know and trust you know dude
i remember staring at my dog's dick for
like
for like two weeks when i was a kid and
that's the name of your memoir
staring at mine i understand at that
thing being like what the [ __ ] is that
that's one of the most phallous things
in nature is the dick of a dog
for something so cute and adorable he
really got shafted on coming out of the
assembly line on that one
anyway okay it yeah it gets i don't know
it gets like a like a uriny smell
because when i put my my my wee wee back
how long are your pubes they were bad
that's what i'm saying like what studio
54.
like give me like they were like draft
dodger
rock and roll bass player that's what
we're talking here
yeah like toby's
i keep my [ __ ] tight son there was a
couple of them that outstretched the uh
the unit itself still dinky
your old tinky winky
that little lincoln lock
the little guy
butt all scrubbed out cleaned that all
up use my brush scrub that clean fresh
as a whistle
plus i started using
um we have to talk about this
prior to the recording you can't just
throw this stuff out at me it's no good
it's not no i'm not saying it's bad it's
just a lot to take in you have to
realize that we're not all walking
around as you so what's normal for you
might be a little startling to those
around you
well i'm sure i know the big guys out
there know what i'm talking about i'm
the point is i'm i'm tackling it head-on
i'm going straight at it tightening
everything up
i use a little uh not vagina
i mean what's the feminine hygiene spray
what
you know what i'm talking about
no yeah it's i think it is vagisil they
use you know they spray it down there to
keep everything dry summer's eve
something like that
i used that yesterday normally i use
gold bond spray after i get everything
all cleaned up i do my hair dryer how
often are you doing this why are we
talking about this
the trim i do as needed but the
scrubbing doesn't sound like you do it
as needed when i realize oh [ __ ] yeah
that's not as smooth it smells
it's like a dead body in an old
apartment you got smelly pubes your ball
sack i get a workout i really have a
long day at the factory a long day
running around i get that i really have
to scrub but your pube smells
just get cold i'm sure your pubes smell
right now
if you scratch out of the shower in an
hour if you scratched your pubes and
smelled it there would be a little bit
maybe a little bleach a little something
my pubes don't i dude i would a hint of
raspberry something i would be on my
pubes notes of vanilla just got out of
the shower are your pubes long
uh right now i don't think so i keep it
pretty tight when you when you when you
trim down do you go all the way i get a
little wacky down there uh
it depends
logo sometimes you go you know it
depends i try to keep an even you know
try to keep it fair and balanced down
there on the left and the right you know
i call balls and strikes this is not
urine by the way
it's not my urine
[Laughter]
i'm not a
weirdo um
yeah i use you know uh i kind of just
give it a quick once-over i go shorter
than i intend to when i start out put it
that way you know what i mean i should
go for like a four or whatever i don't
know i go long i go short i mean
okay i really you know keep it high and
tight down there yeah i used to use a
blade and cream for a long time that's
the most insane thing i've ever heard in
my life oh is it
drinks his own urine and has smelly
pubes i am not drinking my own urine
it's gatorade it's uh red sugar-free red
bull with water
diluted a little bit can't have the
caffeine vanilla something to keep me
going it all goes in the same place
though you know that what's that
you're still consuming the same amount
of caffeine i understand okay so then
why did you just lie a second ago
i don't know
old habits die hard i guess man we are
descending into the ville of foley
i can't probably use a blade and cream i
don't do it no more straight razor yeah
like a bick no straight razor no i'm not
an old [ __ ] barber
in your bathroom with a clown mask on
[Laughter]
yanking my wing out getting the getting
the sideburns yeah you got to pull it
out
that's what i do i pull it out while
she's i get it hard before i do it are
you kidding me
but i would make it easier of course
plus it shows you what the performance
is going to look like not dresser sure
yeah yeah because sometimes you go it
and then you know it's time to perform
and you realize you got a bad do going
you know it looks like you're joining
the arm here
put a hat on that kid jesus christ
yeah you got to go dark for a couple of
days
shut it down
shut down production i'm closing the
studio
[Laughter]
tell me insurance didn't come through or
something i don't know can't find a grip
we're out for a little while yeah
yeah
okay
but yeah i was a blading cream for a
long time wild
get you real smooth down there i know
but doesn't eggs yeah it cuts myself
like eggs
it's a weird comparison this is your
pelvis
and it's as smooth as that yeah
no but when it grows back then you get a
lot of ingrown hairs and like it really
itches as is coming through
maybe i haven't done it in forever hmm
but yeah maybe settle them down you
would do it in the shower i would do it
in the shower and then that's when
you're like oh i've gone too far you
know what i mean
yeah i would go in for a little trim
around like you know the thighs are you
know tighten it up tighten the ship up
they say you know you're knuckle deep
there's a couple of dead bodies and i'm
digging in the cellar
yeah it's real uh real real
it escalates quickly yeah okay
but i've shaved my butthole before you
ever shave your butthole i'll get in the
gooch
you get into gooch yeah see that's a
little bit that's a dangerous area i
also use this i use the same trimmer on
my face and on my balls
yeah
and you're sitting there judging me
yeah i'm clean
toby how do you feel about that super
gross super gross it is what it is uh
what kind of equipment do you use
use the lumbar 1.0 no uh i'll use the
lomo for that you don't use that on you
use the lawnmower on your face sometimes
really my neck okay yeah okay i'll trim
i'll tighten it up with the lawnmower
not just for balls no it's not
this is like ayg after dark what are we
doing here there's a family program your
mothers listen yeah she is
if she does she knows she used to do it
for me before when i was in high school
[Laughter]
mom get down here i got to trim my pews
my i got prom in an hour let's go
tighten them up a little bit
not on oven mitts and bush trimmers
she got goggles
get the big extension cord
the outdoor one the orange one terry
anyhoo
we got a goddamn family episode going on
right now yes we do where we answer your
questions from what was our website
again patreon.com
signed by jack conte and samyam guys
when you sign up for patreon we will
answer your question on air uh it's just
the best way to do it the patreons get
the first crank eat it yeah i mean we
know you know i'm telling him i know you
know i know i know you know that i know
that you know
that i know
sure how much was that jacket too much
200
no
more less
thanks for foley in this game 150 149 45
something like that all right i was
drunk when they got me
and it was one of those things like the
the extra large was too big the medium
was too small and he's like oh we might
have one black large one i'm like let me
came down i was just like it fit i'm
like i'll take it and then i didn't even
look i swiped the card it's like achy
can't let's talk about helix helix helix
helix kippy you know them you love them
you sleep on one every single night i
was in one this morning yes you were so
was i
gang helix let me tell you something you
don't want to be going to the mattress
store like a bozo and dealing with some
dirt ball you can go on helix you can
take the quiz you can find out how you
sleep and they can get a mattress that
matches exactly how you like to sleep
yeah what sounds easy this quiz is
probably what half hour 45 minutes two
three minutes two minutes i took it
myself minute and a half if you cheat me
if you look if you got a nosy neighbor
me and my wife took it we were matched
with the twilight uh
mattress it's fantastic we loved it we
loved it so much we even upgraded to a
king size now we're in there and we use
the promo code garbage there you go you
save a couple of bucks it's easy peasy
if you're looking for a mattress just
take the quiz or the mattress match to
you and it comes right to your door ship
free you don't ever have to go to the
mattress store again
uh just go to helixsleep.com take the
two minutes leave quiz and they'll match
you with a customized mattress to give
you the best sleep of your life 10-year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights free risk-free they'll even pick
it up if you don't love it but i'm
telling you you got the kj stamp of
approval you will love it even got
financing options flexible payment plans
so a good night's sleep is not that far
away helix is offering up to two hundred
dollars off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
healixsleep.com garbage one more time
helix sleep.com garbage do it gang this
podcast is sponsored by better help
online therapy as you know the most
important relationship that you have is
the one you have with yourself you ain't
lying big man which i found out the hard
way not a fan of this guy
and if you need to talk to somebody
better help can actually help you yes uh
it's easy peasy uh better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat sessions with your therapist
so you don't have to see any one camera
if you don't want to but i recommend it
you get the eye contact they pick up
it's easy see how they're living it's
much more affordable than in-person
therapy and you can be matched with a
therapist under 48 hours which is huge
if you've ever tried to get into therapy
uh it can seem daunting and you're
calling people you're leaving messages
or calling you back a week later then
they schedule out 14 months it's this is
easy all under 48 hours you'll be
matched with a therapist give it a try
and see why over two million people have
used better help online therapy this pod
podcast is sponsored by better help and
all you garbage listeners get a 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
garbage that's betterhelp
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com garbage do it yeah
all right let's get right into it
speaking of daily cleaning hygiene look
at that that was not planned that's how
it always works out well it wasn't the
first one i had pulled i wove it in nice
like a pro there you go then bragged
about it uh this one's from kevin james
ryan gosling love the name buddy great
yeah um
never had one red ever use dish soap in
lieu of body wash or a bar of soap
yeah we've we
we've we've touched on this i think a
little bit
for
uh
in the summers when i was landscaping
uh-huh you'd be around poison ivy all
the time oh yeah that so you gotta it
was palmolive
regular palm olive smells so [ __ ]
good
it's unbelievable the blue stuff or the
green the green the green the green get
that goku around the top of that nose oh
when you would run out i would rub my
fingers on that together sure that's
where the flavor smell off yeah
[Laughter]
um
we should you know we would if we the
last house of the day we'd [ __ ] strip
down into our our jean shorts or
whatever we hit on and you stand at the
hose and you'd [ __ ] yeah wash off
with that it's terrible for the skin
it dries out whatever oh my god but i
got used to it and i started using it in
the shower for a little while
i don't there's no shame in it
it's what you got to do that's what you
got to do but like
take me my average day-to-day as you
would call it sure be bopping around the
city couple of spots in the house dog
for a walk come in record whatever
nothing too strenuous you know what i
mean okay i'm not sh a whole bunch of
schmidty
but like i would just clean with water
if i didn't have soap until
like just that one time that i would buy
soap wait what do you mean you would
take a shower without using soap
if i didn't have soap before i use like
palm olive or whatever yeah just [ __ ]
scrub the pitties unless i would use
some conditioner or champ i mean shampoo
is that's the same same [ __ ] buddy i use
shampoo when i have soap oh me too
sometimes i just want the smell yeah you
get like a suave cool breeze yeah take
me right to give me a pina colada and
put my toes in here sometimes i just go
for it she has a really good expensive
shampoo in there all that stuff i don't
touch the cold press grab that
yeah no
uh i use bar soap as a lot of you know
still strict bar man
but if i did run out i would just water
up because i'm not like
that's
that's that's kooky talk
what's the point of death just
man all right but it's also i can't i
can't i'm not judging your lifestyle but
i can't connect to that
is that is that the thing you refer to
as rinsing off
because you use the phrase rinsing off
sometimes i jump in and just rinse off
is that what you call i always use soap
if i'm in the shower i use soap but
here's the also the thing i'm not
getting in the [ __ ] shower knowingly
i don't have soap
i get in the shower i'm soaked i realize
i don't have soap i'm not gonna get out
of the shower
walk into the kitchen
wet as [ __ ] a little hanzi you know
trying to lick my noodle or whatever and
get [ __ ] palm olive or whatever we
use you walk around the house naked at
all
not really no
no i'm rolling around that [ __ ] yeah
like a nude beach in
paraguay uh-uh now i'll be boxers
you know skivs in a t-shirt is typically
like what i snooze in so i'll get up
i'll make some eggies like that or
whatever you know
but that's about it
but yeah no i i would just go like
well this is what i'm this is you're in
that situation but then also i'm in that
situation of i don't have soap i don't
have conditioner i don't have shampoo
like that you can't your conditioner's
off the table what are you talking about
nah you just need something with a
little
conditioner i'm not choose by the you're
acting like i'm telling you to do this
but you're making these decisions
conditioners what am i gonna run to the
store real quick i'm in a goddamn shower
a conditioner
man this kid's like an onion i'm just
saying if i'm in a shower and there's no
soap there's no shampoo
there's just one bottle of conditioner
you're going to get out and go to the
kitchen and get palm olive
for sure that's
that's crazy
get a little lather going get the smell
get a little coconut whatever you're
cooking there's no suds with conditioner
yeah i really i'm operating this is
wartime what are you talking about of
course this is not ideal no
i'd get out of the shower get some soap
that's insane to me you know what patty
did the other day what no your laundry i
disagree
what you know he's not gonna walk and
get soap no you just sit here and lie
and we're just supposed to believe it
there's no way you would walk to the
kitchen and get soaked i wouldn't i
wouldn't use conditioner i know that
having been on the road with you i know
exactly what you would do what's that
you would turn the water off you'd slide
the curtain to the side and you'd yell
until someone brought it to you yeah
that's pretty good
that's what it's like on the road with
foley in an airbnb
would you say that's exactly what i
would know
and i'd be real pissed if nobody heeded
to my to my nobody heard my cries
you stink on every level
that toilet paper uh toilet paper i
think my toilet paper brought to me
oh man
my wife
uh
bought toilet paper at the bodega
because we ran out and like
you can't leave hans is still like you
don't want to leave hans outside you
know what i mean oh what like like wrap
them around like a pole or whatever um i
would do it he's like a full-grown dog
not a puppy it's it's you know gets
scooped up too sweet but
so the only thing like in our
neighborhood to let you go in with a dog
is the bodega so she was like all right
i'll walk you just like you know what
dude
this toilet paper smells like chicken
fingers french fry it smells like it was
in the deep fryer dude i went to blow my
nose with it yesterday would you buy
this at the bodega and she was like yeah
how'd you know i'm like i got falafel in
my nose what do you mean
there's white sauce everywhere
oh dude it smells like dale what's what
these [ __ ] bodegas have no
ventilation the money the dollar bills
smell like grease you're like what's
going on here cranking out [ __ ] bacon
egg and cheeses all day bro open a
window do something get a fan going it's
either that or it's [ __ ] a vile
uh smell of cat litter which is a tough
those typically don't have grills those
typically don't have like the griddles
cooking yeah when you can smell the cat
litter oh
not a fan
[Music]
anyway we're patty to just put a button
on sure let's button it up
she went to do the dishes in the
dishwasher grab palm olive that'll ruin
the floor it was a
five not lying i've done this it was a
five-day process yeah of her constantly
running the dishwasher get the suds out
then the guy had to come out anyway guy
from sears came out took a look at it
yeah wild i know it was a lot i i caught
my wife
did that
down ashore at the house
uh we were out of [ __ ]
uh
what'd she not realize
they don't she i don't know she just
didn't know she was like oh it's soap
you know whatever
um treated me on top of that over there
in europe
yeah i don't know and i was just like
what are you doing i'm like you can't
it's not the same shoe i mean that was
one we did it back we had a babysitter
do it back in the 90s that's awesome and
she didn't know she was trying to be
like i'll clean up for i'll do the
dishes for when the parents get home
whatever
and i mean i remember i remember turning
we were in the family room watching a
movie and i walked out to like get ice
cream or something you know
something real sweet i wanted to do chin
ups
it was to get my medicine ball
is that
kettlebell i guess in the paint dude i
turned the corner and
ah oh my dude it was like a sud monster
coming
it was [ __ ] all over the floor it was
a she i was like yo totes we got an
issue out here
ma is going to be pretty meh
and i'm like i did i was like i told my
mom yo i had nothing to do with this you
know i don't clean you know
is it is this pre pizza or post pizza
this is late night this is like you know
she ran the dishwasher at nine they'll
be home at 10 or whatever
it was late using your dirt bag
tendencies to justify a not [ __ ] up is
amazing oh yeah you know i didn't do it
i'll touch that [ __ ] well it's also
like i just get blame i've always gotten
blamed for everything just sure i'm the
idiot the whatever
um
so i didn't even talk about i guess i
was going to say this for our films but
whatever last whatever two weeks ago i
went down the shore right and
i told you i i talked about it on ayg i
took dirty clothes down to my mom's
house to do and i wasn't staying there i
was staying across the street
um
so i do the laundry
pick it up
that night take it back to the house
whatever
come over in the morning like 10 o'clock
whatever early 8 o'clock
i walk over in the morning
and there's a leak in the drive there's
a leak in the garage
my stepdad's got the ceiling opened up
there's water
and he's got to cut the drywall out yeah
to find the leak he doesn't know where
the leak is coming from so you got to
trace you got to cut you got to open up
the ceiling and trace the leak back i
know
so we're sitting up there and he's going
someone do laundry last night and i'm
like there's no way this was my [ __ ]
what cycle did you put just trying to
pin this on me dude what's up
what the [ __ ] man dude am i i just you
gotta use gentle i'm like i'll be the
guy i broke i i flooded the [ __ ] one
this guy mr [ __ ] permanent press over
here yeah blew out the pipes and half a
wild woods he's going did you shower he
and he was just it was real it was real
trying to pin it on man i got my own
place across the street there's a washer
dryer
also that's your fault if you can't
handle a [ __ ] super load you know
these bloody pipes stink yeah dude you
can't [ __ ] be [ __ ] riding somebody
for now i literally was like dude this
ain't my fault you have a glass of water
up there yeah
who did you make ice or something like
that it was real who's brushing their
teeth i know i'm like sorry yeah and
i don't even know i i i i sounds like a
drain issue i massaged that real quick
but where it's kind of didn't make sense
where it was coming from huh
um
to piggyback onto that one this one's
from grandpa steve long time listen
never question red thanks cramps ever
evict a family member
which i gotta say i was closely almost
evicted by said stepdad
when
i was about 25. he had a he owned a
townhouse rental property sure convinced
him to let me
me and my knucklehead friend did right
we know the story yeah
i didn't know we tried to evict you
the lease wasn't up for renewal let's
put it that way were you late on
payments
there might have been like uh you know
on the sixth or seventh type thing sixth
or seventh waiting for you what do you
mean i'm just saying yeah
this guy doesn't play ball this guy
also he kept the security deposit i want
that out there wow yeah he kept the 1200
security deposit and i moved back
into his house
which was a awkward breakfast to say the
least wait why didn't he let you renew
the lease because he didn't want to deal
with it anymore yeah i think that was it
there's more to this story there's not
really come on
one i probably couldn't afford it
okay i mean if i'm paying if i'm paying
the rent payments late i couldn't afford
it dude two days is not late i
understand i'm telling you i know you're
poking for a deeper story there's not it
was just my roommate was moving out
did anyone is anyone playing along at
home catch what a dirtball foley is what
he said two days is not late meaning the
seventh because in his mind
this is the wind the rent is due and
i've been this one directors do
i'm on his side with that 100 this place
is the 10th by the way i remember
somebody telling me that when i was
maybe like 19 or 18. it was like
discovering the fountain of youth
yeah it's got to be the fifth because of
the social security checks
i had no idea what a social security
check was still no i was not really yeah
but i was a big fan um love that back
when back when i was banging
in my old apartment even this one per
this new one back before we started
making a couple of bucks i'm still doing
the fifth
i'm on autopay now
yeah it's pretty good i got everything
on all to pay but then what happens is i
lose that credit card i forget to re
put in my new one for all my stuff and
then it gets shut off my cell phone gets
shut off has gotten shut off on the past
two past two road dates we went on i got
back remember i got to the airport after
georgia or something yes i get to the
airport i'm trying to call an uber i'm
like this goddamn wi-fi stinks i might
go to make a call
we're redirecting you just written
payment services
send you right over there it's freezing
i got the credit card i'm trying to put
it in they left me high and dry t-bone
and tommy
they send you over there you're in
trouble oh yeah straight to the payment
center for you
and a little trick if you do get shut
down
you can still receive calls i think for
a little bit then they shut that down
after a day or so so get your pager out
get your page route whatever they tell
you hey you got to restart your phone
and wait 15 minutes you don't just throw
it on airplane mode throw it off real
quick re-bust the system that would set
those jackets you've been rocking off
dude what clip a pager
yeah that'd be tight i had a pager
growing up no one ever paged me at not
once i was really upset my dad would
call i'd be at my friend liam's house
i'd be like hey dad page me when you
need me you know what i mean like page
me when you're coming i'll be ready
doing that [ __ ] no he called liam's
house and i'm like your dad's on the
phone what are you doing page me
nobody's pressing pounds not one page
never got one i don't even know the
number way my dad probably gave it to me
it wasn't even hooked up i was like yeah
yeah play with this one i only ever
paged one person coat dealer
it's pretty good
he didn't have a landline
uh
this one all right this is from eddie
lee uh first time brand new have you
ever rolled up a box like it's a bag of
chips to close it i eat a box of yolios
like yes you see what i'm like you curl
it up it took me a minute to understand
hold it in and then roll you like crunch
it yeah a box of eggos would do the same
yes that is a trash move yeah it's trash
it would be a flimsy box that opens from
the end typically a longer skinnier box
i learned toby still can't wrap his head
around that you'd need coal miners hands
to pull that move off no it's thinned
it's like [ __ ] it's just somebody who
maybe worked for a living oh
not behind a keyboard all day it's like
construction important than doing ollies
it's like it's like laminating playing
wiffle ball whatever you and your
buddies are you don't even know what
goes on here
t-bone's
he's just got to show up and be funny
and he delivers
we're having a good time
um
you can do it but it's real trash oh
dude you open if i open up your freezer
and i see a curled up [ __ ] elio's box
i'm leaving i ain't i ain't sticking
around for breakfast what do you live in
whoville
[Laughter]
hooverville no no whoville because it's
curled everything in whoville that was a
deep cut it's a deep cut
jim carrey hit me up i realized you were
so cerebral
um
i learned through many years of trial
and error how delicate
the situation is in the freezer
what do you mean you really got to take
care of your [ __ ] in the freezer because
that freezer burn ain't no joke no
and it really ruins [ __ ]
oh yeah [ __ ] up a pot sticker or a
pierogi before you can even [ __ ]
batter
yeah so the rolling it doesn't help it
doesn't it might buy you 20 minutes or
something it's not
the freezer burns gonna get through your
roll you need hard plastic seal on the
food item and then you need the box
clothes nice yes
let's talk about butcher box baby love
that butcher box yes we do i got a i got
a freezer full of meat to prove it i'm
telling you that right now gang if you
like top quality meat delivered right to
your door we're talking grass fed we're
talking free range we're talking wild
caught salmon pork chicken chops steaks
burgers the whole nine yards yup you
want to get yourself a nice little
subscription to the boys over there
butcher box i love that ground beef baby
the the old lady just made some fresh
meat the balls
i popped you some last night so good
every month butcher ships a curated
selection of high quality meat right to
your home free shipping in a continental
u.s baby look at that i don't care if
you're in texas maine
oregon wherever any use that's 40 states
uh no antibiotics no added hormones each
box contains 8 to 14 pounds of meat
that's insane depending on the box you
choose
that's enough for 24 individual meals
packed fresh shipped frozen for
convenience so you save time in your
next grocery store trip you can
customize your own box or go with one of
the ones they have already curated
either way you get exactly what you want
this is your chance to never have this
is insane chance to never shop for
ground beef again that's right butcher
box is giving new members free ground
beef for life plus a 10 off coupon sign
up at butcherbox.com ayg get your two
free elbows of ground beef freaking
every order all on the arm uh for the
life of your membership plus a ten
dollar off coupon log going to
butcherbox.com
ayg to clean this deal done yeah
athletic greens athletic greens athletic
greens i'm talking about ag-1 don't look
at me stupid i'll come over there and
tune you up cause i'm all jacked up on
that guy's all swollen now he's taking
his ag-1 feel frisky leap baby i started
taking it cause i started working out i
needed something to help me power
through my workouts it's unbelievable i
bring my little shaker with me i drink
it throughout my workout bartender
bench press
i'm taking ag-1 shaken not stirred you
know what i mean
the best stuff ever yeah it's a one-stop
shop it tastes good
gets my gut health going keeps me
feeling good all natural tastes great i
can't say enough about it i swear to god
i take it all the time it's like a soup
if you're if you're new it's like a
super [ __ ] multivitamin it's got
everything you need in the shay it's 75
high quality vitamins minerals whole
food source super foods probiotics and
adaptogens which i still haven't learned
what they are helps the nervous system
immune system energy recovery focus
aging all those things that you need to
take care of it'll charge your phone
contains less than one gram of sugar no
gmos no nasty chemicals no artificial
anything still tastes good look at that
so get involved uh to make it easy
athletic creams is going to give you a
free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase i
took the vitamin d this morning because
we're going on a road gotta have an
immune system pumped up there you go uh
for the meet and greets all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com garbage
again that's athletic greens.com garbage
to take ownership over your health and
pick up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance now backed at a shop back to
the show makes you really want to
kneelios right now though when's the
last time you had one
uh
probably pandemic i would say i had one
i didn't have i was doing the uh
signature selects from acme during the
pandemic that's right crushing them
things i would [ __ ]
i would fill i would cook off the flip
to four cheese
italian sausage i know it cook that
do
three off the rip three slices off the
rip it was like cut into a four banger
three off the rip
i let one sit harden up a bit
start boozing
typically white
what was it white tail wine yellowtail
wine the purple label i think it was a
cab yellow tail on a redneck
start crushing that stuff about a half a
bottle of outlet half the big bottle
what glass are you using for the wine
coffee cup
um
call out my afternoon coffee there's no
shot it was a wine glass
uh
i think it was one of those
i guess it would be a white wine the
short little stubbers like the ones
without the stem on it a goblet a goblet
would be one of those they're close or
just a rocks glass but the goblets we
had down the shore are plastic so i
think i would use a rocks glass
my money was for sure on a triple h
commemorative cup from seminole no no no
no it was a little rocks glass which i
tend to like drink in my wine and even
when i do get a wine at the house or
whatever i'll do a rockstar
i don't know how this is gonna be
perceived and this is strictly my
opinion but i would get drunk and then
have a slice of that with the red wine
about three hours later
cooled down a little bit ice cold oh god
damn freak [ __ ] crust you could [ __ ]
bounce a quarter off of two
damn it not new shabbat
pay you bums off and go have a pizza
somewhere um
those first couple months of the
pandemic the two months
was not too bad
it was all right okay i know that's
[ __ ] up mm-hmm but it was but it was
the world didn't we we were also
powering around a lot because everybody
was stuck at home we started podcasting
every day we'd do hard feelings at ten
o'clock every morning or nine o'clock
we'd have our [ __ ] morning coffee me
and you would zoom for about a half hour
make fun of the birds get some chuckles
going 500 grocery order in the fridge
then order out
[Laughter]
booze stock to the rafters
yeah i know it was a bad time bad time
for a lot of people bad time for a lot
of people we understand
um
here's something you made me think of
when you when you asked about a cup
do you have a cup in your bathroom do
you have like a one of those cups to
rinse whatever you do with it now some
people put their toothbrushes in it we
have one for the toothbrushes you do a
holder for the toothbrush a holder or a
cup a cup it's a cause i think it's a
bathroom cup it's like a
it's like a rubber hard rubber
could you drink out of it sure
we don't because the bottom the inside's
probably a little
icky that smells that's a tough smell um
the old toothpaste we keep our
toothbrushes in there
yeah
i don't really brush i typically always
have a bottle of water so i'll
brush my teeth and then like i use the
wall i use i kind of use it as a spoon a
little bit i know i i do
i don't like doing it i love that um
so i'll like i'll and then rinse that
way and then i hit it with a nice bowl
nice bottle of pole and spring or
something in the bathroom no i'll walk
out and oh okay rehydrate brushing my
teeth dries my mouth out heavy bike
it's like [ __ ] spackle in there or
something
i don't know what you want his nails
this kid
my tongue's dry
i didn't
all right are you done
yeah i'm done okay okay
uh
let's see here
go ahead
get ahead
um guy from maine is your middle name
and nickname my middle name is eddie
instead of edward dude that
stinks
that's bad dude what's your middle name
william
real oh you didn't know yeah hw henry
william foley ii we've gone over this
you're not the second i am the second
[ __ ] i'm named after my grandfather
hey this is a comedy podcast dude what
the [ __ ]
jesus christ dude i called your mom a
[ __ ] 20 minutes ago you get mad at you
you be in the second she had it coming
god damn putting palm off in a
dishwasher patty what are you doing down
there
yes it is chicken that was like a cat
was like a fifth grade fight
i like to hang out i never butt snitcher
this guy's ratting out all the butts
you button arc
real berry dinger
shout out to the berry dingers shout out
to him um
minor league baseball team um what
i'm asking a question on your birth
certificate hold on i'm asking a
question
can you be the second if it's not in
order yes
okay this is a fun this a fun half this
is a fun line of questions
you would be a junior
like if you named hans kevin james ryan
he would be kevin junior
if you skip that it's the second i
called him hans okay that makes sense
but then hans had kids this is human
okay or some type of half-dog half-human
hybrid
which i'm interested in what did you
[Laughter]
to be quiet what did your grandfather do
for a living he was a truck driver he
was a deemster oh yeah that legacy needs
to live on
i worked for friedman's express
holland uh-huh that's how he did it
it's great and to honor him you turned
yourself into a drop yeah
i'm going to be the size of a mack truck
to live to so my grandfather's name
lives on
we're doing the next way into the
buckies yeah
do they have those at bucky's oh they
got everything damn [ __ ] really has
everything
they have a truck weighing
yeah let's guess your weight there's a
guy sitting there guessing
pull right up pull right in ah you're
looking about 18 000 pounds
1805. no we didn't go to bucky's
um
yeah a middle name uh an
uh
aha a nickname as a middle name is a
tough luck i don't understand how that
would even happen what do you mean well
your parents would if they want to call
you eddie or your nickname's eddie
i understand that but you would think
that the notary or wherever the [ __ ] you
get your birth certificate what where do
you get that done sears what do you get
the notary who does birth certificate
the hospital
oh really see yeah
they print them out there yeah you don't
go to like the auto tag place
when you renew your [ __ ]
yeah that's crazy yeah they fill them
out those places always seem like a scam
to me any saturday i went with my dad oh
we were a big do something with the tags
that we were a big auto tags please we
still are bitching we're a big auto tags
family what do you mean
we get a lot of stuff done at the auto
tag place instead of going to the dmv
cause they're on their big thing is
we're online with the state i need a new
set of parking permits can you name my
kid
this is a junior i think
can you stamp his feet can you do the
ink
yeah they do it at the hospital okay so
you would take that weird to go to a
second location to get that done
you're at cvs getting your passport
photos and your kid name i don't i don't
know if you had to go to like uh city
hall or something like that
what do you think happened to the city
hall
uh night court
that's honestly what i think comes out
of that it's just night court and people
getting married uh you are a grade a
bizarre
anyway you would think that the hospital
workers or the administrators or whoever
wouldn't allow you to do that you need
to you need a real name
yeah but these people are clearly
dirtbags i mean yeah sure eddie
yeah i love the name eddie that's a
tough one
that's tough this is another fun one
this is from jordan first time long time
uh is it garbage if i'm a if i'm 22 and
foley is older than my parents
yeah you're a dirtball yeah you're 22.
that means you're no your parents their
parents 23 22. yeah i think that's
exactly what
my parents were when they had me yeah
but times have changed i feel like sure
but you can still do it times have
changed in the regard of you can get
married and have kids later i don't
think there's any shame in
oh no not at all people are still
getting you know people falling in love
finding the right person and getting
married and living their lives
didn't happen for me
better luck next year
uh this one's from taylor ever install a
rollout awning on your
house a roll-out awning uh-huh this is a
deep cut they used to promo these heavy
on like not infomercials but infomercial
type commercials
where it's like 600 bucks or 299.
they're one size fits all you get like
they can get a nine by nine if i can 12
by 12 a big whatever it's real janky it
was the same commercial for about 20
years yes yeah it's an old family
they just so it's really instead of like
building a deck or something you just
set up a couple of lawn chairs and then
just like roll out the awning so you're
in the shade imagine like the side of a
camper that was the um that was the
selling point was in the backyard the
boiling sun right down on you yeah the
dad the jerk off was sitting out there
all cooking couldn't read his magazine
and then he has that thing and he's here
yeah now we're living
yeah i mean i get it they're good but i
do think it's i never thought about it
until this question and i just remember
seeing that commercial five thousand
times they were never put them on the
side of like [ __ ] buckingham palace
or anything you know what i mean
if you could put it on your house and
also an rv it's probably a tough look
and i've said this before and i know
it's a little snappy and refreshing
if
you you can't have all that [ __ ] outside
if you don't have a pool but what are
you doing you have one of those in just
some lawn chairs i just don't get it
there's got to be a pool
but what are you doing
what are you looking at you're just
sitting there looking at the grass
i kind of see what you're saying but
like yeah what i'm saying if you put the
awning out and the lawn chairs and this
and that something somebody like i don't
care if it's a kiddie pool but i think
you're looking at like
august in philadelphia
when it's 100 degrees out if it's a nice
spring night or like you know not
everybody has the same climate so like
it might not get as hot or whatever but
like or even for those days where it's
like hey it's 78
sitting in the back watching the [ __ ]
whatever watching the fireflies yeah
something you know
as i get older sit back there a couple
of beers couple of buddies couple of
heaters call it a [ __ ] day yeah we're
living somewhere like massachusetts
where it's freezing most of the year and
you get like two hot stuff you have a
pool out there yeah i guess you're right
also not everybody's got pool money i
understand completely
mr olympic size in ground pool above
ground pool yeah we don't really have
pool money we got a leak in the pool too
right now
damn a place is going to [ __ ] down here
huh stuff look
it's like yellowstone
you need to hire a couple more hands
random i'll start working for you really
ramming with the hwf
okay i'll kill for you bury a couple of
bodies down by the creek
um
this one
all right so this is this is rare that i
do this this was a bit of a longer
question or so
but then also there was a response to it
because we have like a discussion thread
every week that we post and people a
discord
we do have a discord yeah um but this is
on patreon there's a discussion there
where people chime in blah blah blah
whatever i thought that was called a
discord
continue
um all right
my dad didn't know how to cook growing
up so when mom was gone we ate a piece
of bread topped with a layer of sugar
and then we poured milk over it he
cleverly called it milk bread felt
normal growing up but i've come to
understand this may in fact be garbage
let me know gentlemen and then someone
commented talk about starting from the
back of the pack
yeah man milk bread is a tough luck dude
a piece of bread let me see if i get
this recipe right it's just built bread
and sugar on a plate or a bowl what are
you doing this in yeah i don't know how
that would work i'm assuming a deeper
plate and you would like like a salt
like and just
that's not even a meat like how do you
not figure out macaroni and cheese or
something some eggs or something
something milk bread is so crazy
yeah
you got bread peanut butter jelly toast
i'd rather toast over [ __ ] dude if my
dad or step dad tried to serve me milk
bread at one point i'd [ __ ]
emancipate myself
get the [ __ ] out of here take my chances
on the streets yeah dude
i know find me behind the dry cleaners i
know of an old world
eating hangers uh um
i know of an old world stomach remedy
where you chop where you where you pull
apart white bread put it in a glass with
milk and eat it it coats the stomach and
like i think if you have like heartburn
or indigestion milk of magnesia type
[ __ ] yeah um
it's a base
that's got a function this is just milk
sugar and bread brown sugar some
cinnamon maybe i could see i don't know
the craziest thing is the milk and the
bread is not the most bizarre concept to
me
i can see that
the show you can see a plate with a loaf
with a slice of white bread on it
with milk poured over it well i've just
i've started to pour milk on more things
or i was pouring milk on more things i
don't believe that either way like if i
have a piece of cake you put a piece of
cake in a bowl and fill it halfway with
milk what do we do it's fine it's
awesome it's awesome yeah there's uh
yeah okay
i'm just for fat court i'm just saying
in my old ways
that's something that i would do so to
me that doesn't seem too crazy
the sugar but those things go together
a slice of chocolate cake and milk go
together i didn't say sliced chocolate
whatever it was a slice of
bread and milk don't go together
you see what i'm saying that's not a
peanut butter and jelly cookies and milk
that's not the it's not the case wait
let me ask you this have you ever had a
peanut butter and jelly and dunked it in
your milk and taken a bite of it
sure okay
but that's the peanut butter and jelly
are leading the surge on that not the
white bread i understand
it's playing its part
sure but it's not the part it's that's
not playing the part
that's serving as a vehicle for the
peanut butter and [ __ ] jelly and milk
did you not say there was a response in
there or something like that yeah he
said start about talk about starting
from the back that was it okay
there was no more follow-up as far as no
i'm i'm shocked that you're so thrown by
this would you want it to be savory what
you're saying the sugar is you're jammed
up on the sugar would you want that i'm
just jammed up on the white sugar part
of it i could like i said i could see
some cinnamon
some brown sugar maybe
i'd have to know how it's constructed is
it in a bowl is there more than one
piece of bread how much sugar are you
putting who gives your first of all none
of this matters it is an absolute piece
of trash who gives their kids that for
dinner that's why hillbillies rednecks
those poor kids had to eat in the dark
while they were hiding from social
services too nuts too
everybody hit the deck
there's definitely been times when
that's happened i'm sure
tunnel lights out hit the deck bill
collector somebody showing up
have we ever done that i think we've
done something like that but i think it
was more to avoid somebody we were a big
no phone call
i'm not here my dad we've talked about
right that was never there yeah all of
the 90s you answer the front door
if someone knocks yeah yeah you scope
you peek out the window see what kind of
car we're looking at you know are you
expecting anybody who's that
yeah also my dad like i'm not here
usually the front door was the was the
screener somebody went to the front door
we knew they weren't company yeah it
wasn't it wasn't a friendly no
friendlies come around back yeah i'm
saying ours were coming through the
garage yeah or around back yeah
[ __ ] front door that thing was dead
deadbolted shut yeah with boards going
across it
tough lizard yeah um this one's from zek
have you ever have you or anyone you
sorry have you or anyone you know ever
had a trampoline in your backyard for
more than four consecutive seasons
which i'm confused about
i think this guy insinuates
that you take it down
in the winter what that's crazy talk
crazy and by seasons he means years
i think he means the summer season as
kevin has alluded to yeah i think he
means like
if you leave it up for four seasons this
had multiple likes on it too meaning
they're like oh that's a good question
i get is that a i mean we like we had
had one up for four years straight in
the backyard yeah you would take it can
you take them down don't they get set in
place with the springs and stuff you can
just undo it i guess
i don't know
it doesn't make sense
we never had a trampoline my sister's
got one of that thing's been up for
[ __ ] three four years yeah it just
stays up you go out there in the winter
i think you're real hoity-toity if
you're breaking down and putting it back
up every spring that's wild
that's class
yeah that's pretty good
i mean who's got the room to store that
anyway i know
it's insane you're gonna park the snow
blower you know what i mean oh [ __ ] got
weed in here bro
um
adam h ever used your mouth to get a
good vacuum on a ziploc bag
i never thought of it yeah then you got
what like tomato sauce in your lungs or
something they just
i think i even thought of that it's like
a vacuum sealer yeah i get that how do
you feel about those vacuum sealers we
dabbled in them for a minute oh yeah you
paddy pushing weight
a little bit yeah like putting the
blankets away or whatever the [ __ ] oh
you're talking about the one you
actually attached the vacuum to
oh that's trash dude oh yeah sure we got
one trash really my wife moved here with
one or no she did she bought one or used
hers or bought the bags
to suck it out so because she had to
move all of her clothes here when she
moved they work great so it's [ __ ]
compressed like a whole wardrobe down to
like a [ __ ] size of a t-shirt
yeah it was about too bad he was about
18 000 pounds but still yeah those
things are all right mark dude that
[ __ ] infomercial blew my mind they
would dip it in water pour ink on it
everything then cut it open and like oh
cashmere i was like wow we got to get
this they also had it for for the
kitchen we have one of those as well
never worked
my stepdad would be like you could
marinate montreal chicken in here i'm
like no you can't
hit the [ __ ] scene like a goddamn
michael jackson song oh man [ __ ] hey
i ain't never been to my it's that's no
one's still using that right the first
time i had it i was like what the [ __ ]
is this
this has got everything
that's not fair
everything i've i've i remember the
first we were
my stepdad
was making chicken
it was like a fall night or something we
had to go pick my brother up grill
he was going to be grilling it yeah uh
and then
something happened where my brother was
supposed to get picked up from soccer
practice down in philly but he couldn't
so he got a call like from the other mom
hey we can't get them can you get the
kids it was probably my aunt actually
because they were on the same team my
brother my aunt she was going
shout out to pat shout out to aunt patty
hell of a keeper
she was a big flopper
and i remember
so we had a it marinated for like the
two and a half out we had to drive down
and get hit and came back
and dude um i remember i remember
cutting into this piece of chicken and
being like what in the [ __ ] is this dude
he's like that's montreal chicken i'm
like holy schnikey and then that was
great
but then they changed her he got like
buying off brands
or something well that was mccormick's
was the proper one okay proper labeled
montreal chicken then he started getting
you know trying to pinch pennies and go
in the gym
everything in that [ __ ] for about three
straight years yeah burgers steaks god
damn it that on a [ __ ] piece of steak
trash olaf
um
but the vacuum seal i respect the move
especially when it comes for the
greenery mm-hmm yeah i mean look
um
nice keep my weed fresh this one we this
one's about that's my smoke
smoking weed
um
smoking doobies you know i like an
edward norton every once in a while
and i see eddie
and edie falco oh nice edie falco
all right this one's from petey peppers
uh it's about radar detectors which
obviously we've talked about but this
one did you or did you have a radar
detector installed in your car i had one
that claimed they would pay my ticket
and guarantee it but it only went off
when i drove by supermarkets
that's great dude i mean i could picture
him figuring that out be like slopping
like hey it's in front of the [ __ ]
gennarties every time what's going on
here
oh man man that's true good
we're on a police scanner family we got
to do it uh we were cb my dad and i
stepped out of cb in the ford ranger man
driving down the shore i was sitting
middle seat on that with my brother to
my right my stepdad crank him bernies
man having fun on that cb radio [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh yeah people get get off this
channel baker breaker suck my balls
break a break or suck my balls over
[Laughter]
it was a good time we had a guy come
looking for us one time that's what they
always say that's never they don't know
where the [ __ ] you are
they can't triangulate it what i don't
know
no
no
no let's say for a radar detector
pick up your market
um all right this one's from honey baked
rum ham i like that um filtered have you
ever filtered cheap vodka through a bit
brita pitcher multiple times to make it
better vodka
also then you have a nice cold pitcher
of vodka in the fridge i didn't know you
could do that i think it's
pretty genius that that dropped when we
were in college
you would buy the [ __ ] and you were
on a budget you would buy the pop-off
the what were the other ones
pop-off was the big one we would get it
was like you know of course nine bucks
for the the jug the handle wolferschmidt
or something like that i don't remember
that one there was a bunch pop off and
anything big in plastic big and plastic
yeah at the bottom they're always on the
bottom shelf you know what i mean
get one of those cooking vodka and the
girls
are you guys making penne
[Laughter]
the girls would run it through the brita
so they could make like [ __ ]
vodka tonics or whatever you know
because we were just ripping shooters it
didn't matter to us
pour that in the trash can chop up some
[ __ ] oranges and ice some kool-aid
packets and some [ __ ] lemon yeah
let's make some [ __ ] bad decisions
but yeah it's it's trash but at the same
time you gotta do what you gotta do
something pretty close
that's trash trying to be clear it's not
classy that's not okay open up your dude
if i went to someone's house and i went
to a friend's house today and i opened
up their refrigerator and they had a
brita full of [ __ ] cheap vodka
you'd be like what the [ __ ] are we doing
here you wouldn't be like yeah all right
that's pretty classy you like you have
[ __ ] problems you'd have a drink
though wouldn't you ah yeah we thought
we'd discuss it over a cocktail like
gentlemen
all right we gotta wrap it up gang we
[ __ ] love you we'll see you next week
come see us out on the road on a red on
the road yeah second show at it in
chicago second show out of chicago
denver utah phoenix gang come out and
see us at the live show yes we love you
and we'll see you next week
[Music]